an evil supervillain has taken over our
television sets no it's not the Joker
breaking in to tell us that he's
poisoned the reservoir again I'm talking
about the dreaded mission creep a foul
creature who forces cable networks to
stray from their original programming
directives back in the halcyon days of
the odds cable channels would carve out
their own unique programming niche and
stick to it
a network's name was a tight description
of the shows that you were guaranteed to
find on it
sci-fi channel science fiction American
movie classics classic films made in
America BBC America programs created by
the British Broadcasting Corporation and
shown in America but in an effort to
boost ratings and avoid shelling out big
bucks for syndication rights networks
now show whatever they think will
attract an audience sci-fi channel sorry
the sci-fi channel shows pro-wrestling
no not classic masked luchador films
like Santo versus the Martian invasion
are Blue Demon vs. the infernal brains
that will be fantastic sci-fi shows WWE
Smackdown the same show that used to air
on UPN and the CW apparently those extra
wise in the network's name are for
yeah American movie classics sure some
of the movies a show like Death Wish 5
or Scorpion King 2 or mark for death are
not classic by any stretch of the
imagination but at least those are
movies AMC nowadays is best known for
series television and not just stuff
like madmen and Walking Dead which at
least stand a chance of becoming
classics but how to explain the reality
shows and the ancient westerns rawhide
the rifleman really and why is BBC
America showing the American show Star
Trek The Next Generation is because
Patrick Stewart is British
well jean-luc Picard is French these
networks should get back to their
original programming philosophies even
if it means losing 90 percent of their
viewers sci-fi could just run man sceeto
and Sharktopus more often or man sceeto
versus Sharktopus boom am secret show
classic public domain flicks at no cost
to them I'm talking Phantom Empire radar
men from the moon and it is criminal
that BBC America isn't dipping into its
archives more think of the UK TV
classics a good show like the old
Quatermass serials our blade 7 gurney
slayed fight back cable networks don't
lift the mission creep win what
boneheaded TV network programming
decision chaps your hide tell me in the
comments